ما هو متحف الفشل ، كل ما
يتعلق بمتحف الفشل هو كل ما يتعلق
بمحاولة إيصال مدى أهمية
الفشل من أجل التقدم ، فإن مجتمعنا
يوصم الفشل
إذا أخبرت شخصًا ما أنك فاشل
وهذا أمر سيئ وعلينا تغيير
ذلك كيف حدث هذا  أتت الفكرة بأكملها ،
لقد سئمت من كل قصص النجاح السعيدة اللامعة هذه ،
أنت تعرف
رجل الأعمال الثري اللامع حسن المظهر
على خشبة المسرح قائلاً أوه نعم كنت في
مرآب ، ثم حدث هذا الآن أنا
ملياردير نحن القوة  - تغذى
بسرد النجاح هذا ونسيت
تسليط بعض الضوء على كيفية الوصول إلى
هناك وهذا من خلال الفشل كثيرًا ،
لا يعمل هذا الشيء اللعين على الإطلاق وتعلم
أننا جميعًا نفشل حتى الشركات التي تبلغ قيمتها مليار دولار
في كل وقت تفشل Ford
edsel  من عام 1958 ، فهذه بعض
الإخفاقات التي
من المحتمل أن يتعرف عليها الناس على
الفور ، نعم ، هذه بعض من إخفاقاتنا الغذائية ،
على سبيل المثال ، الكوكا كولا الأسود ،
والكوكاكولا الجديدة هي قصة كلاسيكية من
الثمانينيات ، وهذا خاص بـ loco
i  تم
حظره لأنه كان خطيرًا للغاية ، إنه
مشروب كحولي يحتوي على 12
قلويًا ، إنه قوي حقًا
ومليء بالكافيين ، أعتقد أن المفضل لدي من بين
هذه الشاشة بأكملها هو المشروبات الغازية للحيوانات الأليفة ،
والقطط بنكهة السمك المنعشة تشرب ما
لا تحبه
ماء الكلاب المقرمش بنكهة اللحم البقري ، الأمر كله
يتعلق بدفع الحدود بعيدًا
بما يكفي قبل أن تسقط من الجرف ،
إنها دمية تتجسس على أطفالك
وهنا في متحف الفشل ، يمكنك
أيضًا مشاركة إخفاقاتك حتى
يشارك الناس إخفاقاتهم
لذا  فكرة أنك تكتبها
على الورق وتضعها على الحائط
لذا شاركت واحدة تناولتها هذا الصباح ،
تركت
قهوتي
على
سيارتي ، وأبعدت عن
الفشل الكلاسيكي
الكلاسيكي وهناك قصة فشل حول
بدء متحف  الفشل كنت
متحمسًا جدًا عندما بدأت الموسيقى
عندما خطرت لي فكرة متحف الفشل
الذي اشتريت
متحف المجال الخاص بالفشل.
تهانينا لأنك تمتلك Musum of failure.com لذلك أخطأت في تهجئة
أنا أمين المتحف الوحيد الذي لا يستطيع
تهجئة الكلمة متحف بشكل صحيح ولكن مع
كل خطأ هناك فرصة
لتحسين ما تريد
أن يأخذ الناس منه عندما يأتون إلى هنا
وشاهد هذه المعروضات التي تعرفها إذا
فشلت في شيء ما ، فما يبدو وكأنه
أسوأ شيء هو إذا لم تتعلم
من هذا الفشل ، فهذه
فرصة ضائعة لنكون على استعداد للمشاركة
في مناقشة حول الفشل
وكيف يكون  ذات الصلة بالتقدم